well today would have been the third  birthday for amari nicholson he's the  toddler killed earlier this year  allegedly by his mother's boyfriend now  we talked with amari's father who says  this birthday is especially hard and  amari emory is my motivation because  he's still my baby boy he's still  someone i have to provide for and give  unconditional love  twenty-eight-year-old terrell rhodes  accused of killing amari at an emerald  suites east of the strip back in may  police say rhodes hit the child several  times after he soiled himself amari's  father said rhodes deserves the death  penalty  uh yes yes  because he  he should look deaf in the face like  amari did  it's only fair  you know  it's only fair that you look deaf in the  face like the child did  rhodes trial by the way expected to  begin next year